so brian buchanan just wrote me on
twitter
and said uh something where i said i
wish you could everybody could wake up
and be pumped uh for the day ahead and
he wrote uh
not today and ultimately he said if i
could lose the day job and only focus on
blue dynamic
you cheer me up oh cool look how that
just happened um
so i guess what brian is saying is that
um he really wishes that he could quit
his day job and really focus on his
career building a brand or building a
business online like so many of you out
there that are watching this right now
and i guess what i want to say today is
that you can do both um
you know i had a day job when i was
building wine library tv was running
wine library and then they were much
more connected than let's say
working as an accountant and doing your
video blog on
gardening or karate or 1970s
uh music albums but i really am
surprised that a lot of people think
they have to quit their day job to focus
on building their brand or building
their internet business
and i guess that's what i want to talk
about today you can do both it all comes
down to hustle 2.0 my friends
if you want it you can do it you've got
to give up watching lost
no more weeds no more three hours of wii
no madden football
no halo you know less time going out and
watching movies no dark night
i mean it's all about the hustle if you
want this you can do it and you can have
both
you can work a nine to five and
definitely get home and still spend time
with the family
and then start building your brand or
your business at let's even say
9 00 pm that gives you plenty of time
with the kids and family maybe even
watch
you know a show or two and go nine to
one o'clock in the morning
you know are you gonna live on four or
five hours of sleep for three six
three to six months maybe a year maybe
even two years yes
but if you want to win and when i say
win
to live and do what you want and to
build your business that you want for
yourself
well then you've got to fight for it my
friends the work part is the part that
nobody ever wants to talk about
you've got to work and you've got to
work real real hard
i mean the amount of things that i've
had to give up to create what i've
wanted for myself
has been a lot now i balance it i spend
time with my family and like for example
every sunday i'm watching the jets i
don't care what's going on
you can pay me a hundred trillion
dollars to build your brand apple and
i'm not coming if the jets are playing
but i want people to understand you can
have both just because you work
nine to five in a and in something you
don't love
doesn't mean you can't go out come home
and then hustle four
five six hours to build what you want
and over time it will happen
and you can start transitioning i've
actually know of some people that i've
talked to
about this that have gone from six
figure paying jobs or even high five
figure paying jobs
started building their things started
coming up with some equity some
advertising
and actually took a job that paid them
less but gave them more time to build
their business so they went from being
in corporate america to maybe even
working retail at half the price
but were then able to continue to build
their brand online um or their product
online or their business online
and now we're completely transitioned
out gave up the retail and are doing it
full time you can have both